>> WE HAVE LOST ROSA'S MIC.
THEY'RE HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES.
WE'LL TRY TO GET BACK TO HER.
BRITTNEY GRINER'S COACH SAYS THE
STAR'S DETENTION ISN'T GETTING
AS MUCH ATTENTION AS IT SHOULD.
SHE SAID IF LeBRON JAMES WERE
HELD ABROAD, IT WOULD BE TREATED
MUCH DIFFERENTLY.
>> IF IT WAS LeBRON, HE WOULD BE
HOME, RIGHT?
YEAH.
IT IS A STATEMENT ABOUT THE
VALUE OF WOMEN, IT IS A
STATEMENT ABOUT THE VALUE OF
BLACK PERSONS, IT IS A STATEMENT
ABOUT THE VALUE OF A GAY PERSON,
ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
AND WE KNOW IT, AND SO THAT'S
WHAT HURTS A LITTLE MORE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT WITH
CARI CHAMPION, JOURNALIST AND
HOST OF "NAKED WITH CARI
CHAMPION."
IT IS TOUGH TO HEAR HER SAY
THAT.
YOU THINK SHE'S RIGHT?
>> NO, SHE'S ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
IN HER DEFENSE, AS WELL, I WAS
VERY PROUD OF HER COACH, THE
MERCURY HEAD COACH FOR SAYING
THAT BECAUSE IT IS A VERY REAL
THING AND IT IS TIME TO SAY THE
QUIET PART OUT LOUD.
I THINK BRITTNEY'S LETTER SHE
WROTE YESTERDAY THAT WAS
DELIVERED TO HIM FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING AND THAT HE WAS
READ WAS VERY CLEAR AND THERE
WERE EXCERPTS FROM THAT LETTER
WHERE SHE DESCRIBED WHAT SHE
FELT SHE WOULD HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE, MEANING NEVER
LEAVING THIS RUSSIAN PRISON.
AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THAT.
SHE IS SOMEONE'S DAUGHTER.
THE HUMANITY PART OF THIS IS
VERY DISTURBING.
AND, BRIANNA, YOU SEE THIS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HEAR ENOUGH
ABOUT IT.
I THINK THAT WE IN THE MEDIA ARE
DOING OUR BEST TO GET THE WORD
OUT, BUT THERE IS THIS APATHY
TOWARD BRITTNEY GRINER WHICH IS
SO DISTURBING, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT WHAT COULD POTENTIALLY
HAPPEN TO HER.
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING, LESS THAN
1% OF PEOPLE WHO ARE TRIED IN
RUSSIA ACTUALLY GET ACQUITTED,
SO THAT MEANS THERE DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE ANY OTHER OPTION BUT SOME
SORT OF JAIL TIME FOR HER.
AND IF THAT IS THE CASE, I WANT
US TO PUT ALL EYES ON HER.
THIS IS IMPERATIVE.
SHE'S OUR SISTER, SHE IS
SOMEONE'S DAUGHTER, SHE IS
SOMEONE'S WIFE, SHE IS -- SHE
HAS A FAMILY AND WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT IT THAT WAY.
>> I THINK COMPOUNDING THIS,
TOO, IS THAT INITIALLY, YOU'LL
HEAR THIS FROM MANY PEOPLE WHOSE
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE DETAINED
ABROAD, THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
TO BE QUIET BECAUSE THEY'RE
TOLD, YOU KNOW, BE QUIET, THIS
IS VERY SENSITIVE, YOU DON'T
WANT TO JEOPARDIZE THE RELEASE,
BUT EVENTUALLY THEY LEARN THEY
HAVE TO MAKE SOME NOISE AND I
THINK WE'RE REALLY TO THAT
POINT, WE'RE SEEING CHERELLE
MAKE A LOT OF NOISE, AND SHE IS
SORT OF OPENING THE DOOR PERHAPS
FOR OTHER PEOPLE TOO.
WHAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
ATHLETES, OF OTHER PEOPLE OF
NOTE TO MAKE SOME NOISE?
>> LOOK, IF SHE IS NOT FREE, I'M
NOT FREE.
IT IS EVERYONE'S RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT WHAT HER WIFE
IS DOING.
THERE IS MESSAGING WE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THE LEAGUE AND THAT
WE HEARD INSIDE OF OUR STUDIOS,
IF YOU WILL, LET'S NOT TALK
ABOUT IT, LET'S NOT PUT TOO MUCH
ATTENTION ON IT.
THAT MESSAGE HAS TO BE TURNED
AROUND, THAT NEEDS TO BE FLIPPED
UPSIDE DOWN.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT WILL
BRING HER HOME.
I DO BELIEVE THE COACH IS
CORRECT IN SAYING IF THIS WAS
LeBRON, WHOM EVER, BUT WE CAN'T
PLAY THE IF GAME NOW.
TIME IS RUNNING OUT.
AND SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO, MUCH
LIKE THE WIFE IS DOING, SHE'S
FED UP.
SHE'S TIRED OF PLAYING THE QUIET
GAME, AND WE'RE SAYING THE
UNCOMFORTABLE PARTS OUT LOUD.
SHE IS BLACK, SHE IS A WOMAN,
SHE IS A LESBIAN, DO WE CARE
ABOUT HER?
AND IT SEEMS LIKE WE DON'T.
IF THIS LETTER DID NOT HIT, YOU
KNOW, PRESIDENT BIDEN IN HIS
HEART AND MADE HIM FEEL LIKE WE
NEED TO RUSH TO ACTION, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT ELSE TO DO OTHER THAN
SCREAM VERY LOUDLY.
I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH NBA
PLAYERS WHO HAVE DONE ALL THEY
CAN POSSIBLY DO TO GET THE WORD
OUT.
THEY'RE FRIENDS WITH HER.
STAR NBA PLAYERS ARE FRIENDS
WITH BRITTNEY GRINER, AND
THEY'RE WEARING THEIR SHIRTS,
THEY TALK ABOUT IT DURING THE
PRESS CONFERENCE, OTHER ATHLETES
ARE DOING IT.
WE'RE DOING OUR BEST IN TERMS OF
BEING VOCAL, BUT NOW WE NEED A
CALL TO ACTION.
AND THAT IS TO OBVIOUSLY CONTACT
YOUR LOCAL CONGRESS PERSON, BUT
WE'RE NOW GOING TO THE PRESIDENT
AS DID BRITTNEY GRINER AND SAY
WE NEED HELP.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, I THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THE TIME